this is the aftermath of two days of
sporadic fighting in tripoli
muhammad says he and his family were
trapped in the crossfire on thursday and
friday
we were living in fear some families
were stuck inside and others were able
to get out only god knows what we went
through and as you can see many homes
were damaged
the violence between the special
deterrent force and the presidential
guard broke out when the rival groups
traded blame for kidnappings
both are part of the libyan government's
fragile security services
fighting took place in heavily populated
areas health officials say
women and children are among the victims
the u.n special advisor on libya
stephanie williams says she is outraged
by the violence adding that civilians
must be protected and perpetrators held
accountable
prime minister abdul hamid david has
suspended interior minister khaled
al-masin of his duties until an
investigation is completed
he's been temporarily replaced by this
man
we've established a committee to assess
the damages incurred by private citizens
so they can be reimbursed we've launched
an investigation into this incident and
have developed a security plan so that
events like this won't be repeated
but people are angry
muhammad says the minister's visit to
his neighborhood is too little
too late
the government doesn't care about us the
ministers are coming now what do we want
with them now after the fighting stopped
after our homes were destroyed we don't
need them now
the un mission has urged all libyans to
preserve what it says is the country's
fragile stability
negotiations between the rival
legislative houses have been stuck in a
political deadlock
but people here want authorities to
force armed groups out of the city
so that incidents like this
don't happen again
malak trainer al jazeera tripoli